today we're taking a look at a section
of animal crossing that is often
neglected and that is your campsite
[Music]
people of the Internet retro raconteur
here your guides a family friendly
content in the world of video games so
I'm gonna take you in my campsite now
here's my little dude retro raconteur
he's pretty happy right now because he
is super pumped on the campsite that
we're getting ready to show off to you
guys so here we go we're gonna go up
this ramp right here and as you can see
here we had some flowers on each side we
got the little sign right here we also
have a well on this side I've got the
leaf pile here also another well here
now if you go over here we really made
an effort to make this look very rustic
so you can see all the flowers that we
have it just kind of randomly scattered
about couple trees here and then you
have the nice little area or the swing
right here where you can sit back relax
and enjoy the nice soothing sounds of
the waterfall if you guys are looking to
make improvements to your campsite make
sure you go ahead and leave me a comment
down below let me know what you are
trying to do in your island and we're
gonna make our way up here as we head
into the main entrance of the campsites
we got a nice big waterfall there we got
camping sign here and you just love how
the music kind of dips into the
background there so you can hear the
waterfall right there just pause and
listen for a moment
just glorious just glorious if you
position yourself just right you can get
a little bit of the waterfall the
crackling fire here and also the outdoor
baths it's just a glorious very peaceful
sound here as you stare at the night sky
so again this is the main entrance to
the campsite here we've got the little
cooler here a couple lawn chairs also a
picnic sleeping back here as well as the
camping cot always important to have
them lantern nearby toolbox in case
anything goes wrong as well as the radio
here also a clothesline for you to hang
all your clothes here while you're out
in the wilderness who needs a clothes
dryer really got the little kiddie pool
here to keep the kids entertained also a
fenced in area so don't have to worry
about them falling into the waterfall
got a nice little hammock for here
parents will have to be a little bit
more careful so you don't fall into the
waterfall there got the wheelbarrow here
in case you want to do any work and
gather some dirt here got the generator
here in case you need any extra power a
mini fridge and above it the little mini
stove if you bring the pets along got a
little spot here for them to have their
dinner and also a telescope so you can
stare up at the night sky
alright so you may think the telescope
is the end of the tour at least on this
side of map but not so fast because if
you look closely here there's a little
secret path that's gonna take you around
the side of this mountain here so it's
kind of a little hidden path and in my
mind I kind of envision people going
hiking as they go around the mountain
here to get an even better view of the
waterfall from a completely different
vantage point
Oh present got to make time for the
present
let's see what it is
10,000 bells let's go baby let's go now
if you're wondering about these extra
little mounds here I actually discovered
that the game will let me build up to
that level however it will not let you
add anything on top so you see the
message they're saying it's dangerous to
climb higher same thing if we go and try
over here if I try and climb up right
here it's gonna say it's dangerous to
climb any higher so you can't build
those mounds up but you cannot put
anything on top of them and whenever I
think of a camp
I think of campfires and so sitting here
by the fire is my favorite place to be
you've got the crackling of the fire you
got the radio over there on the side if
you want it and also the sound of the
gentle waves rushing down the waterfall
here now that's not the end of our tour
just yet if you head out to the left
let's say you wake up in the early
morning you want to go for a little hike
so as you head out on the trail you're
gonna find some trees here to your right
and also the bamboo noodle slide is I
believe the name of this you can craft
it once you learn how to use bamboo also
another leaf pile here to the side but
if you follow this trail it's gonna be
like a little hike through the forest
wooded area here now if you head down
this ramp here that's gonna take you
into another section of my island stay
tuned for a future video but if you stay
up top here instead that's gonna take
you to a nice little spot here where you
can sit back relax and enjoy some peace
and quiet at the pond while maybe
getting in a little fishing as well we
got it let's go dude an atlas mom now
for a while I actually left weeds on the
ground for a nice little aesthetic but
instead I've decided to go with the leaf
pile instead now if you pay close
attention here
there's actually a shortcut right there
we can jump across the pond across the
waterfall and go into a completely new
section
now with the entrance area right here
what I was really focused on is making
this a very photogenic opportunity so if
you pull out your camera from this spot
right here you'll see the fact I can
actually get a really good angle to
where I can get the nice night sky in
there I can also get the fire in the
background as well is the camping sign
and if i zoom it out just a little bit
you can see a little bit of that noodle
slide over there on the left as well
this is actually a great shot right here
get the moon in the background as well
lawn chairs let's go ahead and snap that
photo the campsite is an area that I
feel like is just way too often
neglected and I got to give a shout out
to n64 Josh here great youtuber he gave
me a lot of ideas for my campsite in if
you've gotten any ideas from this video
be sure and give me a like down below
just noticed here gotta get rid of these
extra flowers here there we go much much
better much better so my main focus of
the campsite was to get connected with
nature so you see a lot of elements with
the natural environment such as the
water here we've got the crackling fire
over there you've got the flowers as you
enter here the wells as well as the
swing so you can really just sit back
relax and enjoy nature the way it was
meant to be and that is gonna conclude
it for today's video be sure and check
me out live on twitch.tv slash retro
raconteur also if you've got any tips at
all from this video be sure you give a
thumbs up down below and if you want to
see more videos like this make sure you
hit that subscribe button so you don't
miss any of our future videos that's it
for me today I will talk to you again
very soon
[Music]